بدا الشغل على الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه والرئيس السابق للمرشح الحالي
دونالد ترامب شغاله حملته واعلاناته على
كل الاصعده وطبعا اسلوبه في الهجوم على
خصومه معروف واجدد الخصوم منافسه في قلب
حزبه حاكم فلوريدا
من الاول نازل في هجومه واهانات ايمين
ويسار
اسمه
بيسميه يعني
اللي هو اسمه كده انه بيجمع فيه بين اسم
رون وبين كلمه منافق بالانجليزيه طيب
عموما مثل ما سمعتوا ترامب بيقول انه لدى
ديسنتس او انه
انت بحاجه لعمليه او لعمليه زراعه شخصيه
تحديدا الهجوم موقف هنا مو شايف انه حاجه
اخاف مشاكله عند تراب يعني لا شايف
المشكله انه في شيء مختلف اكبر
يعني مو المشكله انه الرجال محتاج زرع
شخصيه لا المشكله انه العلم لسه ما توصل
لهذا النوع من العمليات يعني زي بقول له
مالك امل يعني فيعني فوق الاهانه جرح
اضافي عموما تفضلوا اسمعوا التصريح كامل
وشوفوا الصفحه الافتراضيه اللي وجهتها